buenos días y muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24 para esta
entrevista en exclusiva con el ex
presidente de brasil luiz inácio lula da
silva en este momento estoy en san paulo
en la sede del partido de los
trabajadores con fanny lotes mi colega
la corresponsal del canal en francés de
france 24 buenos días señor presidente y
muchas gracias por conceder otra
entrevista a nuestro canal buenos dias
valeria usted pasó casi 600 días en la
prisión por corrupción pero en marzo de
este año el supremo tribunal federal
anuló todas sus condenas porque el
tribunal que le condenó no tenía
competencia de un día para otro usted
volvió a ser de nuevo elegible y ahora
es el favorito en los sondeos para las
próximas elecciones de 2022 parece que
en poco tiempo usted pasó de ser
considerado el culpado de todo a ser
visto como el salvador del país usted se
siente el salvador de brasil
fanny yo no soy el salvador de la patria
ni quiero serlo
tengo una visión del país y una visión
del mundo de la política yo creo que la
solución de brasil pasa por el hecho de
gobernar para las personas más pobres
del país
es preciso que coloquemos a los pobres
dentro de los presupuestos del estado
cuando tienes que discutir la totalidad
del dinero que el estado recauda y los
redistribuye entre los miembros de la
sociedad por favor coloca en primer
lugar a los pobres porque si no lo haces
sabes no sobrará dinero para hacer
políticas sociales ni en brasil ni en
ningún país del mundo en un país del
mundo en todo un vil agravio e incluso
entonces mi milagro fue incluir al
pueblo brasileño en las grandes
decisiones del país cuando fui
presidente yo hice 74 conferencias
nacionales para discutir qué políticas
públicas implantar en brásil
esta práctica dio resultados y por eso
es que termine mi mandato con un
crecimiento en brasil del 7 5% en la
inflación totalmente controlada y
nosotros generamos la mayor cantidad de
empleos formales de aquel momento
histórico mientras que en el mundo
desarrollado
europa y eeuu 6 millones de personas
perdieron su empleo aquí en brasil
conquistamos 22 millones de nuevos
empleos life conquistamos vinci y 2
billones de nuevos imperios obras y
libro brasil se ha convertido en un
paria internacional por causa de una
gestión caótica de la pandemia hoy hay
más de medio millón de muertos y muchos
países prohibieron la entrada de los
brasileños por miedo de las variantes
que surgieron aquí usted ha criticado
bastante a jair bolsonaro considerándolo
y culpado de todo pro usted qué habría
hecho como habría lidiado con esta
situación porque aconteció el himno
donde puede mire lo que pasó es que él
no cuidó de la pandemia él no creyó en
la ciencia él no confió en la medicina
él inventó un remedio él no quiso
comprar la vacuna cuando había el no
incentivó el uso de la mascarilla no
incentivo a las personas a quedarse en
casa para evitar aglomeraciones
sabe de las personas y karim cada diez
bitar volverse político digo bien por
eso digo que él es responsable de una
parte
540 mil brasileños y brasileñas que
murieron por eso lo llamo genocida en
algún momento él va a pagar por la
irresponsabilidad que tuvo en cuidar de
la salud del pueblo entonces que creo
que debería haberse hecho un presidente
de la república que ya tenía información
porque el commit empezó en china y pasó
por una parte de europa debería haber
preparado a los científicos brasileños
el deber ya te prepara 200 para libros
podría reunir podría haber reunido al
ministro de salud y a los secretarios de
sanidad de cada estado crear un comité
de crisis crear un protocolo nacional
para que las personas recibiese en la
misma información oficial basada en un
criterio científico formación oficial
más allá de un criterio científico no el
himno por lo contrario él no creo nada
de eso se peleó con los gobernadores con
los alcaldes con los laboratorios con la
agencia que autoriza los medicamentos se
peleó con la cámara de diputados con el
senado con la corte suprema se peleó con
todo el mundo entonces hoy en brasil
estamos recogiendo el resultado del
incompetencia de un genocida y un
genocida se note usted repitió en varias
ocasiones que en 2022 brasil tendrá que
escoger entre la democracia de lula y el
fascismo de versionar o no obstante en
el congreso hay más de 30 partidos una
comisión de investigación en el senado
que cuestiona la gestión de la pandemia
por parte del gobierno y una corte
suprema que actúa con bastante
independencia no cree que fascismo es
una palabra un poco fuerte no sería más
correcto hablar de erosión de la
democracia
no no es una palabra fuerte parece muy
fascista porque comportamiento y por sus
agresiones él agrede al pueblo a las
mujeres a los negros a los sindicalistas
a los trabajadores a los ex presidentes
de la república es inadmisible esta
grosería parece que es un ciudadano no
civilizado sabes es preciso traer un
poco de civismo para que él aprenda a
convivir o mandarlo a una escuela para
que haga un curso de relaciones humanas
convive o coloca él en una escuela plaza
de un curso de
entonces tenemos que entonces tenemos
que ser duros con él porque él
efectivamente es eso él solo se respeta
a sí mismo y los millones de face news
que produce cada día usted sabe que en
los últimos días salió un informe que
revela que el cuenta de media cuatro
mentiras por día 4 y 4
ahora observa ahora jair bolsonaro ha
lanzado una batalla contra la 'urna
electrónica' que es una característica
del sistema electoral brasileño él
quiere volver al voto impreso incluso
llegó a decir que sin voto impreso no
habrá elecciones presidenciales el año
que viene eso sería un golpe un golpe
mire creer en las tonterías que dice
bolsonaro es creer que vamos a volver a
los tiempos de los dinosaurios
wat electrónico el voto electrónico
posee una prueba de que es honesto el
hecho de que lula ganó las elecciones en
este país porque nadie imaginaba que un
trabajador metalúrgico podría ser
presidente de la república y nosotros
ganamos en 2002 en 2006 en 2010 en 2014
y no ganamos en 2018 porque fui
arrestado no gay
word y nombre a 2017 porque fui preso y
me emprender edad y me arrestaron
exactamente para evitar que concurriese
en las elecciones entonces está
comprobado en el mundo que el voto
electrónico es una de las formas más
eficaces usted termina de votar a las 5
horas de la tarde y a las 72 horas
después ya saben quién es el presidente
de la república de este país con 213
millones de habitantes si hay una cosa
que funciona en brasil es la urna
electrónica fui a una electrónica
o sea fue acusado por corrupción usted
fue acusado de corrupción y ahora el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro está siendo
investigado por corrupción por una
supuesta trama de sobornos en la compra
de las vacunas desde un punto de vista
exterior parece que en brasil la
política está siempre asociada a la
corrupción en brasil no hay política sin
corrupción
yo voy a repetir una cosa en mi caso ha
quedado probado que fue construida una
mentira incluso con la participación del
departamento de justicia de los eeuu ya
está aprobado que el departamento de
justicia junto al ministerio público de
brasilia un juez
preparó todo tipo de denuncias para
intentar impedir mi candidatura
yo fui juzgado yo fui investigado yo
preste declaración en 24 ocasiones en la
policía federal en el ministerio público
y ante el juez te después me to yo fui
24 de dispuestas de impedimento en
supuesta devuelve la policía federal no
visitar buscar suites un botón
bolsonaro no deja que su familia declaré
ni va a prestar declaración y ya
existen pruebas robustas de la
participación de su familia en un
esquema de malversación en río de
janeiro ya hay pruebas contundentes que
todavía no están confirmadas porque no
hay un informe final de que hubo
corrupción en el ministerio de salud por
causa de las vacunas entonces yo no
estoy diciendo que él es corrupto yo
digo lo siguiente que se ponga desnudo
delante de la justicia como lo hice yo
que enseñarla pero señor lula en el
congreso además de 120 solicitudes de
impeachment contra jair bolsonaro usted
ya dijo públicamente que a estas alturas
no hay tiempo sin embargo recuerdo que
prácticamente en el minuto 90 del
partido intentaron hacer el impeachment
contra tonadas trampa por eso me
pregunto no sería más interesante hacer
en elegible ayer personaron mediante un
impeachment as oa lo mejor una
polarización lula bolsonaro es más
provecho de las urnas beneficiosas las
urnas no siento decir polarizadas según
la persona mire no es necesaria la
polarización entre lula y bolsonaro
bolsonaro tiene que perder las
elecciones porque el pueblo brasileño
derrotará a bolsonaro el pueblo
brasileño conquistar a la democracia en
este país este país quiere volver a ser
un país civilizado ya se han presentado
más de 125 solicitudes de impeachment el
presidente de la cámara de diputados
tiene la facultad de ponerlas en el
orden del día para su votación y no lo
está haciendo ahora mismo hay una
petición de impeachment firmada por
muchas autoridades públicas pero en este
momento no hay voto presencial en la
cámara todo se hace virtualmente el
presidente de la cámara no está bajo
ninguna presión entonces no la pone en
el orden del día yo creo que ya sea a
través del impeachment ya sea a través
de una interdicción firmada por la corte
suprema o con las elecciones la realidad
es que estamos cerca del fin del
gobierno de este genocida llamado
bolsonaro mató postular un discurso
gatica el discurso radical de
evolucionarlo ha provocado cada vez más
ataques contra periodistas ecologistas y
políticos incluso la caravana lula fue
atacada durante la última campaña
electoral
no tiene miedo de sufrir un atentado
durante las próximas elecciones si llega
a ser candidato de focalidad muchas
personas trabajan conmigo y todas están
preocupadas por mi seguridad a mí
sinceramente eso no me preocupa a través
de un trabajo pues ya conté efe que va
en pérdida democracia y esto aconteciese
quien pierde es la democracia es brasil
que pierde pero sinceramente espero que
no acontezca la ignorancia la
radicalización el odio que había en
brasil lo que hemos visto en los eeuu
control creo que tenemos que trabajar
para intentar mostrar a las personas que
cuando ponen su voto en la urna también
depositan su esperanza en la urna no
depositan odio si yo pienso que los
políticos en brasil no valen nada
entonces que yo sea el candidato aunque
se lo acreditó usted va a ser calidad
craft finca
porque es así como vamos a cambiar el
mundo
puedo decirle que llegado el momento de
decidir si yo tendré la misma salud y
las mismas ganas que tengo ahora
entonces si puedo decirle que seré
candidato
buffet candidato
señaló la obra se vendió lula brasil
vive una situación paradójica por un
lado es uno de los mayores productores
de alimentos del mundo y en los últimos
años batió todos los récords en la
exportación de soja por ejemplo al mismo
tiempo está volviendo el hambre que
afecta a más de 19 millones de personas
la inflación está por las nubes y afecta
sobre todo el precio de los alimentos y
hay mucho desempleo si consigues volver
a gobernar cómo piensa reactivar la
economía brasileña en un mundo post
pandemia post pandemia son paradox
dauman y esta es la paradoja de la
humanidad porque la humanidad produce
una cantidad de alimentos superior a lo
que la sociedad puede consumir sin
embargo al menos el 30 por ciento de
estos alimentos desaparecen entre el
momento en que son producidos y el
momento en el que llegan al mercado otra
parte se pierde durante el proceso de
industrialización y hay gente que no
come porque no tiene dinero para comprar
comida si tuviesen dinero lo que no
falta es alimento
de alimento
él tiene una cosa importante que es la
combinación de la capacidad productiva
de la agroindustria y la capacidad
productiva de la pequeña y mediana
agricultura brasileña lo que aquí
llamamos agricultura familiar que
alimenta el 70% de la población
brasileña por lo tanto en brasil la
hambruna no debería existir lo que falta
es dinero para que la gente pueda
comprar alimentos es decir para las
personas comprar pero cómo desarrollar
brasil sin destruir la amazonía
preservando los derechos de los pueblos
indígenas y al mismo tiempo agradando a
la mayor economía de brasil que es la
agroindustria parece una ecuación
imposible
no es imposible es de ignorantes creer
que para aumentar la producción agrícola
hay que invadir la amazonía y las
tierras indígenas es pura ignorancia
por eso yo digo que evolucionaron es un
genocida su cabeza no piensa en hacer el
bien sólo piensa en hacer el mal
que utiliza
busquets y utilizar el kers mira
deberíamos utilizar la riqueza de la
biodiversidad de la amazonía para poder
producir otro tipo de oportunidades
otras fuentes de empleos y de riqueza
para la región y dirigir para región
josete extraodinaira capacidad de la
industria fármaco hay un potencial
enorme en la industria farmacéutica por
ejemplo o en la industria cosmética es
preciso valorar a las personas que
protegen y cuidan de los bosques es
posible conseguir que todos los parques
nacionales sean cuidados por los propios
indígenas que viven en la zona por los
trabajadores locales y generar otro tipo
de empleos sabes
fanny yo era presidente cuando creamos
el fondo amazonía con la participación
de noruega y de alemania hay dos errores
que estamos cometiendo no podemos
aceptar que un país diga que la amazonía
debe ser internacionalizada porque la
amazonía es un territorio soberano de
brasil y podemos aceptar la idea de que
la amazonía sea convertida en un
santuario de la humanidad
la idea de maradona transformada en un
santuario de la humanidad señor lula a
sus adversarios critican su proximidad
con los gobiernos de cuba y venezuela
que usted siempre apoyó abiertamente en
los últimos días vimos muchas protestas
en cuba de personas que pedían más
libertades vimos también la represión
tanto de periodistas como de activistas
en el año 2021 es posible defender el
actual gobierno de cuba y como pero no
se trata de defender lo vendió miran no
se trata de defender al gobierno cubano
valeria si usted retoma todo lo que he
dicho sobre cuba
primero yo soy un demócrata y segundo me
gustan las elecciones tercero no creo en
el sistema de partido único no creo que
sea la solución pienso que debe haber
una disputa política una alternativa en
el poder es este ejercicio civilizatorio
de la democracia que nos permite crecer
civilizatorio la democracia que permite
a la gente presionar
ahora bien usted no precisa estar de
acuerdo con la forma en que se gobierna
en cuba creo que cuba necesita tener el
derecho a decidir soberanamente lo que
quiere hacer decir a ellos y que yo pero
me dio un poco de rabia cuando usted
habló de la violencia de la policía
cubana
valeria yo veo la televisión cuando hay
una huelga lo que hace la policía
francesa con los trabajadores con los
chalecos amarillos yo veo lo que hace la
policía en alemania o lo que hace en
eeuu y sobre todo aquí en brasil
entonces en cuba o la misma agresividad
que hay en cualquier otro país del mundo
la misma agresividad que en qué país del
mundo
dejemos que los cubanos decidan por sí
mismos sin que el embajador
estadounidense se atribuye al derecho de
decidir lo que hay que hacer todos los
países tienen que tener el derecho de la
autodeterminación de sus pueblos
eliminación de estos pueblos
muchas gracias señor lula por esta
entrevista en exclusiva y gracias a
ustedes por acompañarnos se les
invitamos a seguir nuestra programación
en france 24 y france24 puntocom